vamos con el problema 55 en el problema
55 dice que en cierta reunión a cada uno
de los invitados les tocó un postre o
dos postres entonces un postre postre o
dos que tampoco fue o sea es un postre o
dos y lo que nos interesa es saber a
cuántos les tocó doble a cuántos a
cuántos les tocó doble doble muy bien en
el enunciado de información número uno
nos dicen que al 60% de los invitados
les tocó doble vamos a ponerle nombre a
cada una de las variables vamos a
llamarle ve a la cantidad de invitados
que les tocó doble y 1 a la cantidad de
invitados que les tocó un postre
entonces nos están diciendo que el 60
por ciento de todos los invitados es
decir qué 0.01 0.6 de todos los
invitados de demás un les tocó doble
entonces esto de aquí es igual
ahora esta información por sí misma no
nos permite determinar de por qué aquí
todavía está aquí todavía está esta
variable que nos está estorbando
entonces pues está esta de acá por sí
misma no nos permite determinar el valor
de d vamos a ver qué sucede con 2 con el
inciso de información 2 nos dice que en
total se sirvieron 120 postres ok en
total se sirvieron 120 postres bueno a
cada a cada persona que le tocó un
postre pues pues les tocó un postre
verdad y a cada una que le tocó doble
pues le tocaron dos postres entonces
esto es la cantidad total de postres que
se sirvieron una vez a los que le tocó
uno y dos veces a los que le tocó dos y
nos dicen que eso de ahí es igual a 120
bueno de lejos ya podemos decir que con
las dos que con las dos igualdades
podemos resolver el problema está por sí
misma no funciona porque estorbaba ésta
por sí misma no funciona porque porque
estorbaba pero si juntamos las dos
tenemos dos ecuaciones lineales en dos
variables y bueno tendríamos muy mala
suerte si no se pueden ver
así que si tienes prisa en el examen de
james lo que te recomiendo es pues ya de
una vez ponerle la opción c la opción se
que es que por sí mismas no nos dan la
respuesta pero juntas si como ahorita
tenemos un poco más de calma vamos a ver
que de adeveras eso funciona lo que
vamos a hacer es es despejar y de aquí
entonces vamos a hacerlo en amarillo
para que no sea tan monótono vamos a
despejar un nos queda que i
es igual a 120 menos 2 de y ahora vamos
a substituir está aquí arriba vale
entonces nos quedaría 0.6 por demás es
decir 120 este bueno el primero voy a
poner la ven déjame ponerla de por acá
de massú que 120 menos de más 120 menos
2 de perdón 2 de esto de aquí es igual a
de y de esta de esta ecuación de acá
pues podemos determinar el valor de de
ahora es lineal en de nada más nos queda
haber 0.6 por ciento veinte es 72 6% ajá
entonces nos queda 72 de menos 2 de es
menos de entonces menos 0.6 de es igual
a de de aquí tenemos que 72 es igual a
1.6 y bueno de aquí podemos dividir
entre 1.6 para determinar el valor de b
pero ya no haremos eso entonces lo que
nos importa es que juntando las dos si
podemos responder la pregunta de a
cuánto les tocó doble va
vamos ahora a hacer el 56 con otro tono
de verde el 56 nos dice nos pregunta
cuál es el valor de xy cuál es el valor
de xy y la información que tenemos en el
inciso 1 es la siguiente en el inciso 1
nos dice que es igual a x + 1 por
supuesto esto no es suficiente por sí
mismo porque pues cada valor de x tiene
su valor correspondiente de g y quién
sabe que sea el producto el inciso 2 nos
dice que es igual a x al cuadrado más 1
que por supuesto tampoco funciona hay
muchísimos valores de x que satisfacen
eso y que no tienen producto constante
entonces el chiste sería ver si entre
las dos si entre las dos podemos
determinar el valor de xy bueno no hay
que irnos con la finta es que sean dos
ecuaciones no quiere decir que tengan
solución única porque no son lineales
aquí hay algo al cuadrado entonces vamos
a hacer un poco más cuidadosos vamos a
pensar que las dos se satisfacen y
entonces lo que sí podemos hacer es
igualar
entonces juntando estas dos juntando
estas dos obtenemos que x
es igual a x1 restando uno de ambos
lados tenemos que x cuadrada es igual a
equis restando x tenemos que x al
cuadrado menos x es igual a 0 y factor
izando x tenemos que x por x menos 1 es
igual a cero entonces tenemos dos
chances o este término es cero o este
término es cero
si este término es cero vivimos en un
mundo donde x es igual a cero
y si este término es cero vivimos en un
mundo donde x es igual a 1 y x es igual
a 1 sale entonces tenemos estas dos
posibilidades vamos a ver si estas nos
dan el mismo valor de xy va a ver si x
es igual a cero entonces de esta
obtenemos que es igual a 1 entonces esta
es una solución del sistema de
ecuaciones va entonces y es igual a 1
por esta o por ésta
ese fue el chiste de igualar y si x es
igual a 1 y es igual a 2 ya sea por esta
o por esta y es igual a 2 entonces
tenemos esas dos posibilidades y cuando
es xy en cada caso pues acá x es igual a
cero cero por una es cero y acá xy es
igual a dos entonces pues no verdad no
podemos determinar este sin ambigüedad
cuál es el valor de xy aun que
combinemos las dos igualdades si
supiéramos más por ejemplo no sé qué x
es positivo o que x es positivo entonces
podríamos determinar el valor de x pero
así como nos lo dan estas dos no son
suficientes y por lo tanto la respuesta
es
sale la respuesta es que muy bien vamos
ahora al problema 57-57 en el problema
57 nos piden determinar el valor de 1
entre x + 1 entre y creo que ya habíamos
hecho uno igualito verdad bueno para
resolver esto lo que habíamos hecho era
desarrollar esta expresión simplemente
esto de aquí es igual a bueno vamos a
hacerlo un poco distinto esto es igual
hay entre xy estamos haciendo esto para
poner un denominador común esto
simplemente es uno entre x + x entre xy
sale aquí x se cancela con x y es uno
entre y y por lo tanto esta expresión es
igual a x más entre xy vamos a ver qué
información nos dan en la información 1
nos dan nos dan la suma nos dicen que x
+ es igual a 14 a 14 bueno pues esta
información de aquí no es suficiente
todavía necesitamos el producto vale
vamos a ver que nos dan en la 2
seguramente es el producto si mira nos
dicen que x es igual a 24
sale entonces ya teniendo estas dos
podemos encontrar el valor de de esta
fracción teniendo una cada una de éstas
por separado pues no tenemos una pieza
del rompecabezas el numerador o el
denominador pero no la otra entonces por
separado no nos ayudan pero juntando las
dos sí y por lo tanto la respuesta es c
s como tenemos bastante tiempo de hecho
hasta podríamos calcular cuánto nos da
osea sabiendo que x es 14 y que x 24 nos
queda lo voy a hacer un poco más grande
nos queda 14 entre 24 y simplificando un
poco dividiendo entre 2 el numerador y
el denominador nos queda 7 entre 12 esto
no lo tuvimos que haber hecho pero bueno
ya lo hicimos por si nos daba curiosidad
problema 58 voy a ponerlo por aquí abajo
vamos a ponerlo en este color naranja
problema 58 en el problema 58 nos dice
que de es un número decimal que es un
número decimal y nos preguntan
si d es mayor o igual que 0.5
si d es mayor o igual que 0.5 bueno en
el inciso de información número uno nos
dice que cuando redondeamos de a la
décima más cercana nos queda 0.5
entonces al redondear a la décima 10ª
nos queda nos queda 0.5 esto todavía no
nos permite afirmar o determinar si d es
mayor o igual que 0.5 verdad podemos
tener por ejemplo que de fuera que de
fuera 0.47 y entonces al redondear a la
décima se va a 0.5 y en y en cuyo caso
es menor que 0.5 o bien te puede ser
0.50 y 252 digamos y aquí al redondear a
la décima también nos queda 0.5 y bueno
arriba si si más bien arriba no queda
mayor que 0.5 y abajo si entonces sigue
habiendo ambigüedad esta información por
sí misma no es suficiente
y en el inciso 2 lo que nos dicen es que
cuando d se redondea al entero más
cercano el resultado queda 1 entonces al
redondear al entero más cercano
nos queda uno pues eso básicamente es
decir que es mayor o igual que 0.5 no o
sea si el número más chiquito que se
redondea a 1 es 0.5 verdad 0.5 o
cualquiera superior a ese bueno pero que
no sea muy grande se redondea a uno
digamos entre 0.5 y 1 y cosas como 0.4
999 99 que son menores que 0.5 se
redondean a 0 cuando se redondean al
entero más cercano entonces si saber que
se redondea aún no nos permite concluir
que es mayor o igual a 0.5 entonces aquí
la respuesta sería sería que la primera
no nos permite determinar la segunda así
y eso es el inciso b vamos a dejarle
hasta aquí le seguimos en otros vídeos